شاب كان يعتبر الطفله المعجزه في عالم
العملات المشفره ذلك الشاب والفارس الابيض
كما يسمى خطف الاضواء بصعوبه وخطف الاضواء
بسقوطه المدويه سقوط مدونه
في يوم واحد 15 مليار دولار يتحدث طبعا عن
عبقري تشفير سام بانكمان وطبعا يبدا انه
هارب الى جزر البهاماس لكن ما الذي حصل
بالتحديث
او غير حقيقيه لم يتضح الامر بعد الاشاعه
افادت بان منصه لن تكون قادره على دفع
اموال عملاء فتهفت العملاء وسحبوا سته
مليارات دولار خلال اثنتين و 70 ساعه فقط
طبعا هذا التهافت اسقط منصه واسقط ايضا
الفارس الابيض واعاده تساؤلات حول
مستقبلكته
[موسيقى]
المستثمرين في الصدمه انهيار دراماتيكي
لاكثر شركات العالم استقرارا في مجال
التشفير ما الذي حصل يعني لازم نعرف احنا
مثل اي شركه مثل اي انسان
ما يعرف الميزانيه شو عليه مدفوعات يكون
عم بيجيب مصاري او من الاصول
الالتزامات عم ترتفع بطريقه اكبر من
الاصول راح يكون عنصر لما يعرف
السؤال هلا كيف قطعت كل هالمده وما كان
حدا ملاحظ يعني هلا اذا فيه عمل لها حفظها
دلوقتي
نعتبره
باكونت مختلف او منفصله عن الشركه ولا هو
بين ايدين شركه انها تكون عم تستعمل وهذا
الكلام بيصير طيب فرح اليوم صرنا عم نسمع
اكثر عن افلاس العملات المشفره وتراجعات
في السوق العملات المشفره هل هذا يعني
بدايه نهايه العملات المشفره ولهذا كلام
مبالغ فيه يعني فينا نقول ايه لا يمكن
الوضع بيشبه نوعا ما لكن عم نشهدوا خلال
دوت كوم بابل اول ما بلش التكنولوجيا
الانترنت كنا عم نسمع كثير من الاصول كانت
او شركات عم ترتفع بشكل كثير كبير من
بعدنا شفنا انه هل هذا الشيء يعني انه وقت
الانترنت
نستعمله قديش هذه الشركه فعلا اقدر اتقدم
لنا خدمات تضل معنا لفترات طويله
في الامتحان
من بعد ما وجت بنسميها بالاسواق والسيول
العاليه هلا عم نشوف مين كان عنده فعلا
الشريكه مدعومه او الاصول مدعومه كمان في
حال المستثمرين كان بدهم اموالهم واي منك
كانت بس مستفيده منها اليوفور في الاصوات